i wanted to hear that with conviction i
want to hear it because i don't know if
you can see it wrong but i didn't get no
chance world class
have you got a world class midfielder
your team huh have you got a world class
midfielder too yeah who what's an edward
martin older guard is world class
yeah
[Music]
you've got the most positive arse off on
here well there's a good reason on top
of the league listen bloody how's the
season finished can anyone confirm the
season finished
this is not over he's got a trophy there
or something seriously you've got any
jokes in the last five years listen
don't worry man you guys protect this
cfa cup but honestly i wouldn't be
surprised it's behind you now yeah the
news has just started relax you know i
mean there's no gold trophy like last
time that you keep talking about
manchester united will finish above
arsenal this season
three
two
one
you see a hesitation
that's hesitation you're not sure i'm
sure strongly disagree with chest
listen
what can you say that you can tell me
that you tell me that what are some
officials yeah you've got the best
strike in the world got the best defense
in the world got the best midfielder
dude
you're talking for me is that your
argument you answered your own question
that's what i'm hearing that's what i'm
hearing you're hearing us
let me know what you think i think it's
more you guys you
listen all i'm saying to you is here the
manager's here now we've got a coach now
a proper proper coach that you've seen
him in europe you've watched him in
europe don't know if he's watching
europe you've seen him in europe you've
seen what it's done you've seen the the
squads that is managed we know where
we're going now we've got finally we've
got a manager now we believe in arteta
what's he done at your football club
that you can believe he's gonna finish
above above united well arteta is done
yes stabilize the club and we should be
a blueprint
what we're doing now is what you want to
do
spending money and directions after
spending 400 million
[Music]
as long as your captain's hiring him and
going out today
he's not there he's dropped well like
you've got varane and we've got lisa
martinez is it what's he saying about it
and you got you got a center back that
you loaned up for two years and all of a
sudden he's the best seller back in the
world might be he's better advise you
he's better than yours i thought you
were sending back slightly what the [ __ ]
you could say you all said about
spiderman yeah what are you talking
about
any defenders better champions
it's a europa league variant now isn't
it well this is a process
what did you say for three years
right trust a hospital's process because
you need the same the question was who's
finishing above who and i think you
agree because you put agree up but
strongly disagree i agree with that
definition above arsenal and how's that
i think we've got the manager i think
we've got the players now i think we've
got the belief now listen you know that
more than me where start the season and
it could end well yes or no so in the
days we're going to go to this process
we're going to believe in the manager
and step by step nothing happens
overnight the series has not started
this is not finished yet and i firmly
believe with the cohesion we've got and
the manager you can't tell me that our
tattoo is better manager than 10 hours
can you say that yes i can because i've
watched arteta manage and you've
launched any games at 10 or listen
doesn't mean that i've watched it so you
say that how can you judge
so how can you tell me he's going to
outperform tenant he's on a trophy so
what makes you think also going to
finish above united apart from the fact
that we have a better attack better
defense better midfield oh my god but
you're actually a little better manager
have you have you have you just
literally written the script to
liverpool better oh it's not really hard
better than myself
about best defense and all that where's
your amount of arsenal how do you firmly
believe do you disagree
do you think you've got a better defense
than arsenal i think we've got a better
defensive last year and how can we
continue all goes on this last season
again last season is right nick why
don't you just judge it on this what
about this season so how many of you
guys
how many guys you guys left back we've
got how many clean cheeses martinez have
zero farmer
season season it's not finished money
wearing mouth is
where do you think united's finishing
top off fourth
fourth yeah
that's realistic and i know that's what
the first season of ten arc that's what
we're aiming for i know there's teams
that are in a more bigger progression
for me fourth i know where i'm finishing
fourth
i don't say second you don't stay second
oh dave you've asked me have you
go on dead where are you finishing the
season dad
dude yeah
you literally just
oh my god i've got confidence you're
going in the middle so you're saying
so the process is to finish eighth
eighth sixth and the third
after spending 450 minutes
yeah and you keep saying that you're
finishing both top again for the first
time how many years you know i don't
count wow cause you don't count because
that's how bad you've been i got my
trophies you can't you're trying one one
trophy so you're lapping up again one
trophy again fourteen fa cups will be
exact thirteen new titles
man for man
arsenal's team is better than manchester
united's
three
two one
please van please please don't even oh
my god i think you should move this as
well if you have any common sense please
but i'm not surprised united fan go on
give me a delusion then please man let
me hear the world for this one you're
going to say ravenclaw how are you going
to shout out
are you going to say ramsay's kicking
therefore means he's better than david
de gea is that what you're going to do i
mean i say that he's a good goalkeeper
then i'll watch the game against
brentford oh so one game again what is
this with us fun one game game here and
then you get three games
ramsdale's been relegated twice in his
career it does one kick he does camera
says after camera says and all of a
sudden you think he's the best keeper in
the world we're talking about a guy
who's in his peak powers
and he's um spain's four choices
has come from the championship spain's
flute now i'm talking about daea de gea
okay spain's fourth choice goalkeeper
fulfill the shows
behind brighton's goalkeeper
you think he's better though
right now is england no so there you go
so what are you talking about
because he can kick the ball therefore
he can go into the spade squad you may
be your teammate you you give me your
analysis i think you'd be lucky to get
two players in the arsenal team if i'm
being pitiful you know that's why i
think we're strongly finished above you
so you've got the best track of the
world as well i'm not saying the best in
the world but you're not the best in the
world i think right
for man most of our team it's better
than your team we've got center backs
out of bed united
as well i don't know i'm not sure so you
don't want to add him i think he could
get on the team maybe he's one of your
players
what yeah i think he's one of the
players
i wanted to hear that with conviction i
want to hear it because i don't know
because it made it wrong bro i didn't
get no chance world class
have you got world class midfielder in
your team huh have you got world class
midfielder yet yeah who wants to know
about it
martin odergaard is world class
the guy that's got about five goals last
year creating chances how many how many
chances you create last season i think
the second verse in the league wow
you're calling world class based on that
what does that mean if he's not no bad
female listen you're a good guy i know
and i'm a clever guy as well
listen i know you're clever you've
served your waffles
[Music]
it's not twitter you're just giving me
little opinions give me [ __ ] there's no
we can't do that
when it comes
[Music]
sorry who's got a better right-wing i
think student central
i think steve sanchez
you can't provide the basis on that when
southgate's a manager you know already
southgate should be picking better
players so we can't we can't disclose to
sanchez school last season i said same
as gabriel
in terms of saving
for man it's a new season man for man
sancho is clear everybody knows the
talent of jaden sancho everybody knows
and sakura listen star boy this and that
i give him his credit but i'm taking
sancho and i think most people will
agree on it sancho for me is clear again
name of a profile do you order
you look at even his qualities though is
it you know if you look at his
attributes sancho is clear everything if
you look at its technical qualities
clear what makes them
what makes them clear hey what makes
them clear it's technically wise yeah
but what makes them technically good
technically it doesn't dribble in
dribbling better is he easily better
come on man listen listen that's a lot
better skill still skip who's the better
he's got five or four skills he's better
than zucker now two you just asked me
the attributes
right now
no i'm not playing for you play fifa i
don't play people actually
i don't care how many maybe the players
are getting our team
the chao
for rams okay that's it i don't need to
hear anymore
the game gets into your team does he the
gail you're gonna get in spain's team oh
yeah he does again brentford's team
forget awesome are you gonna hit me up
for
left back as well malaysia who you've
got left back sinchenko zinchenko teeny
listen i think for me
you've you've not played an argument in
your midfield you said older guard
oh midfield is erdogard jakka pate who
did you get fixed gets in my united team
um ramzo comfortably because my keeper
players are the back i'm i'm a person
that is in a modern era of football
not in 2013 when united standing
trophies
modern era rams dog gets on the team
right back tom yasser gets in the tomb
this is not about him
even ben white gets overwhelmed
hello is the right back
you can't make positions you can't make
positions that'll always all right
cedric is better than the law oh my god
left we've got two better left backs
teen is a chance i don't think you can
argue against
central banks casimiro in the midfield
oh no let's go center backs why are you
moving forward are you a bit scared
about sending back now i've been
securities i've already said it center
backs i think which also stand back to
get in your team so leave it i'll give
you that comfortably celebrity gabrielle
listen come on ben white ben white come
on they're both getting no they're
sandra martial i think i'll be lucky to
meet the bench
because if you're talking about tommy
ass's fitness and same overview the
sandra martinez
he's not going to give me that one the
midfield options who's getting the
midfield options casimiro is getting in
there you've got bloody um erickson's in
there erickson's the net for eric
erickson eric said you wouldn't die for
erickson you can't tell me erickson
wouldn't get into that i watched him
against brentford i was so jealous yeah
one game so so jealousy i was like why
is he not playing
foreign gabrielle jesus will score more
goals for arsenal than all of united's
forwards this season
three two one
you know what i'll give him some respect
all of your strikers are one player you
deepen how bad that is for your attack
and this is a fourth place attack he
said as well i disagree man i prefer not
to speak gabriel's
what's the highest goal tally of gabriel
isis i think 14 14. and you quite
disagree
14. you don't even believe in your
attack lava i thought sancho was the
next big thing no i i don't know i don't
believe i don't know the question was
gabriel zeus will score more goals
i know because he won't because he won't
cristiano ronaldo is still there we've
got martial still there we could
possibly buy a striker martial's still
there yeah marshall's still there
martial still proven end of the day
right
but hey jesus this this this so-called
world-class striker jesus has only
scored 14 goals you still have to deep
that there's no comments within you that
he will score 25 goals he clearly is my
friend strongly agree
on what about basis of what what pet me
subscribe right here
all of a sudden he's going to be
confused
will make more chances he'll stop more
older guys oh the wizard of oz
the wizard older guard is going to oh my
god you've got osaka you've got martinez
you've got fabio vieira smith rose and
there many more listen
cristiano ronaldo still got 18 goals for
my united last season is it martial
where did i get again martial
talk about goals
we'll get more goals than all of our
strikers i agreed i agree again ronaldo
got 18 goals last season yeah we've got
a new manager for martial we've got
we've
no but you got to realize though we've
got more of a solid bases now to score
more goals tactically my united will be
astute more better here it is united to
score more goals right now you can't
tell me jesus you have more confidence
in jesus god 14 goals the highest
for man city to replicate them goals for
arsenal you can't you can't say it i've
got facts to back that hey you know what
it is that was
a season
20 21 league games i asked but he'll
start 35 more chances more starts more
goals
and and hence why older guys will score
well we'll assist would be the wizard is
that what you're trying to say yeah it's
not just early guard you've got more
players we've got you don't believe in
ronaldo
here we go just because you know you did
a video with chris oval now all of a
sudden your best friend
you know what for me like i said i'm not
gonna lie to you i bench warm up all of
a sudden but man city comes to arsenal
it creates this big atmosphere what not
and then all of a sudden bang he out
scores ronaldo who's caught 80 goals
last season maddie would never scored
more than having said 14 goals you got
still got uh martial in there i'm sorry
man i'm gonna have to firmly disagree
man manchester united should now be
considered the biggest banter club in
the premier league
three
two one
even he hesitated you see that listen
your club is getting violated by the
producers are you playing against man i
might have to have words with you know
this one part of the script
[Music]
[Music]
i think for me like i said to you we've
been in a transition any club we've been
in a transition
transition
but again it's been dropped we've been
in the transition oh hurry back and
forth
manager now we've got a new system we've
got a new culture now we're going to be
changing things slowly but all of a
sudden for people for arsenal fans to
look down on my united who are the kings
of banter club by the way who every
single time
we look we look forward every single
time for the [ __ ] meltdown every
single time it's always around the
corner with united now we're going to be
entering a new period now under 10 hang
and we've got we we we've got a
longevity with this manager you don't
have that longevity without your manager
why is that not because you know around
the corner after spending that 400
million you know around the corner if
you don't meet his objective he's going
to get sacked whereas my manager's got
time he's got time to build here your
manager he's on he's running out of time
he our chat is running out of time are
you sure he's got i don't know i know
you think eric 10 months got time
for more than 10 months listen
respect to my mother more than 10 months
are you willing to put money on the fact
that he will stay more than 10 months
easy
listen wherever you're pricing it no
your price you decide
what's your fault hundred pounds there
you go i don't back out i'm liking that
okay
arsenal fans are the most deluded in the
premier league ah
two one
you know what buzz man
here because it's not no no no no stay
ready
please
the amount of stuff that's come out of
your fab base is absolutely crazy
you know that already
explain give me examples the amount of
nonsense your family's come out of the
amount of hype that your family has come
out of and yet again and again what
happens man what happens the meltdown is
always around the corner above it's
always around the corner and i see you
at in the season oh next season next
season your next fan base is deluded man
you know what it is it's another this
guy is calling us looted and you call it
maguire better than van dyke listen
bring your receipts he's calling us the
receipt he's calling us
he called
like i said to you your meltdowns are
always around the corner yeah
you talk about this you talk about that
you might have just deluded man you have
got no substance what you say you come
out with all this crap another day the
same old same moment nothing ever
changed that are you my friend it's
always banner everything i've just
perfectly described my united fans
amazing i couldn't describe it any
better you hear yourself all right there
you go man it's
i mean been a pleasure
in person it's made me think differently
man yeah i know yeah you're a good guy
you're a good guy i still think you're
delusional
[Laughter]
so peter is over now